NATIONWIDE WHO PUT THEIR PEOPLE,
THEIR SAFETY AND THEIR
WELL-BEING FIRST.
JOINING ME NOW IS OHIO
CONGRESSMAN JIM JORDAN RANKING
MEMBER OF HOUSE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE AND MOLLIE HEMINGWAY
EDITOR IN CHIEF OF THE
FEDERALIST.
CONGRESSMAN IT'S NICE PRESIDENT
BIDEN DID FINALLY REACH OUT TO
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS.
BUT HE ALSO DECLINED TO CANCEL A
FUNDRAISER TONIGHT TO HELP MORE,
YOU KNOW, OBVIOUSLY DEMOCRATS
GET ELECTED GOVERNOR.
WHICH JUST SEEMED, I DON'T KNOW,
SEEMED OFF.
I DON'T WANT TO POLITICIZE THIS
BUT IT DOES SEEM OFF.
>> AND IF PRESIDENT TRUMP DID
THAT YOU CAN IMAGINE WHAT THE
LEFT WOULD SAY AND YOU'RE
EXACTLY RIGHT LEADERSHIP
MATTERS.
WE HAD GREAT LEADERSHIP FROM
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND GREAT FROM
THE GOVERNOR.
THE GOVERNOR SAID THEY ALREADY
HAVE 40,000 LINE WORKERS ON
STAND-BY NATIONAL GUARD ON
STAND-BY.
THEY'VE GOT PLANES READY TO GO.
I THINK YOU TALK ABOUT AIR, LAND
AND SEA READY TO HELP THE
RESIDENTS AND FAMILIES OF HIS
DISTRICT AND ALREADY SET UP A
WAY TO RAISE MONEY FOR THE
FAMILIES WHO WE'RE ALL PRAYING
FOR WHO ARE GOING TO BE IMPACTED
ABOUT THIS AND AS YOU POINT OUT
JOE BIDEN IS RAISING MONEY FOR
HIMSELF AND THE DEMOCRATS THE
PEOPLE GIVING US ALL THE
PROBLEMS UNFOLDING ACROSS OUR
COUNTRY WHETHER IT'S CRIME
BORDER INFLATION THE LAST 20
MONTHS.
SO LEADERSHIP MATTERS AND WE'RE
SEEING A CONTRAST THAT WE HAD
UNDER REAL LEADERSHIP WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THIS
GOVERNOR AND BIDEN.
>> AS DeSANTIS PREPARES FOR
FLORIDIANS HE'S URGING TO HEED
ADVISE FROM THE SAME LOCAL
LEADERS HE SUGGESTED IGNORE
DURING COVID AND PRAISING A
FEDERAL AGENCY THAT HE
PREVIOUSLY SAID WITHHELD AID A
BECAUSE BIDEN WAS PLAYING
POLITICS.
MOLLIE WAS HURRICANES AND COVID
THE SAME.
>> IF YOU UNDERSTAND THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN HURRICANES
AND COVID CONGRATULATIONS YOU'RE
SMARTER THAN A CNN REPORT
RAILROAD.
THERE HAVE BEEN PROBLEMS WITH
MANAGEMENT PARTICULARLY AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL AND FLORIDA
EMERGENCY EXPERTS ARE
UNFORTUNATELY SANDY IN THIS TYPE
OF CA AT THAT TIME CONTROVERSY,
THEY ARE GIVING GOOD ADVICE, IT
IS WISE PEOPLE LISTEN TO THOSE
LOCAL EMERGENCY LEADERS AND JUST
MORE THAN THAT, THIS IS NOT THE
TIME TO BE PLAYING THESE KINDS
OF GAMES.
I GET THAT REPORTERS HATE RON
DeSANTIS.
THEY HATE THAT HE'S VERY
EFFECTIVE.
>> Laura: THEY DESPISE HIM.
>> AT PUSHING BACK AGAINST THEM
AND OTHER PEOPLE ON THE LEFT BUT
THE REASONEN HE'S SO POPULAR
ISN'T JUST BECAUSE HE PUSHES
BACK AND OTHER CRAZY NEST OF THE
LEFT IT'S BECAUSE HE'S A GOOD
DIN STRAIGHTER.
WHEN PEOPLE GO THERE WHETHER
THEY'RE REPUBLICAN AND DEMOCRAT
THEY PRAISE HOW HE KEPT THE
STATE OPEN DURING COVID HOW HE'S
FRIENDLY TO THE BUSINESSES.
THEY LIKE HIS POLICIES, NOT JUST
BECAUSE HE'S CONSERVATIVE.
>> Laura: IN THE END GOVERNMENT
IS SUPPOSED TO WOULD BEING FOR
THE PEOPLE NOT CONSPIRING
AGAINST THE PEOPLE AND WE SEE
THAT HAPPENING IN VARYING STATES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY BUT FLORIDA
IS REALLY A SHINING EXAMPLE
ALONG WITH TEXAS AND TENNESSEE
AND SOUTH DAKOTA AND IOWA.
THEY'RE STATE THAT ARE ACTUALLY
RUN WELL.
>> YEAH, AT HE WE THE PEOPLE,
NOT WE THE GOVERNMENT.
WE THE PEOPLE ELECT FOLKS TO
MAKE DECISIONS, NOT THE
BUREAUCRATS LIKE FAUCI WHO THINK
HE'S SMARTER THAN EVERYONE ELSE
SPEAKING OF COVID.
GREAT LEADERS UNDERSTAND THAT,
OUR CONSTITUTION STARTS WITH
THOSE THREE WORDS WE THE PEOPLE.
THEY GET THAT.
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS, PRESIDENT
TRUMP, THEY GET IT.
UNFORTUNATELY TODAY'S LEFT WHICH
RUNS OUR FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
THEY DON'T.
THEY THINK POWER'S ALL ABOUT THE
GOVERNMENT AND THE BUREAUCRACY
AND DOING WHAT THEY WANT TO DO
VERSUS WHAT WE THE PEOPLE
ELECTED FOLKS TO DO.
>> Laura: I WAS TALKING TO
SOMEONE THE OTHER DAY AND SHE
SAID TO ME, NOT REALLY A
POLITICAL PERSON, AN OLD COLLEGE
FRIEND, AND SHE SAID, I START TO
THINK LIKE, I FEEL LIKE I'M THE
ENEMY IN MY OWN COUNTRY.
I FEEL LIKE I'M AN ADVERSARY TO
THE PEOPLE WE VOTE FOR OR WHO
ARE SUPPOSED TO SERVE US AS
OPPOSED TO THE POLITICAL PARTY.
LIKE WE'RE THE ENEMY.
NO, WE'RE THE PEOPLE WE'RE NOT
THE ENEMY.
DON'T TREAT US LIKE THE ENEMY.
THE HURRICANE IS SLAMMING
FLORIDA.
JOHN KERRY THOUGHT IT WAS THE
PERFECT TIME TO TOUT BIDEN ON
THE CLIMATE.
>> THE INFLATION REDUCTION ACT
WILL BE AN ACCELERATOR OF
ACTION.
IT HAS REALLY SERIOUS MONEY AS
INCENTIVE FOR THE DEPLOYMENT OF
RENEWABLES.
FOR THE MANUFACTURE OF
FOR THE DEPLOYMENT OF ELECTRIC
VEHICLES, THE INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
IT.
THIS IS A JOB CREATOR.
>> Laura: MOLLIE?
>> THERE IS THIS WIDE HELD
CONSPIRACY THEORY ON THE LEFT
THAT MANMADE CLIMATE CHANGE IS
THE CAUSE OF HURRICANES, WHICH
IS JUST ABSURD ON ITS FACE.
WE'VE HAD HURRICANES EVER SINCE
THE DAWN OF CREATION.
THEY AVERAGE, YOU KNOW, I THINK
THE AVERAGE NUMBER OF HURRICANES
FROM 1851 TO 1860 WAS 19.
THAT WAS THE SAME NUMBER THAT WE
WILL HAD BETWEEN 2011 AND 2020.
THERE ARE MORE PEOPLE LIVING IN
COASTAL REGIONS, THAT DOES MEAN
THAT COSTS GO UP WHEN HAINES
HIT.
BUT THERE'S JUST NO EVIDENCE FOR
THIS THEORY THAT PEOPLE KEEP
HOLDING.
AND THEN ALSO, THE NUMBER OF
YEARS -- EVEN IF YOU BELIEVED
ALL OF SORT OF THE PROPAGANDA
THAT COMES WITH THE LEGISLATION,
THE NUMBER OF DECADES IT WOULD
TAKE TO BEAR FRUIT IN TERMS OF
ANY OF THIS WOULD -- IT WOULD
NOT HAVE MATTERED WHEN THEY
PASSED THIS BILL.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN BEFORE WE
LET YOU GO ON THE ISSUE OF
INSURANCE AND THE FLOOD ZONES
THIS IS A HUGE ISSUE PLAYING OUT
ON THE COASTAL ISSUES OF THE
COUNTRY A LOT OF INSURANCE
COMPANIES PULLING OUT ALL
TOGETHER THEIR LOSSES HAVE BEEN
SO BIG THEY CAN'T STAY IN
BUSINESS.
WHAT IS THE ANSWER BECAUSE THE
FEDERAL FLOOD INSURANCE COVERS
VERY LITTLE.
>> YEAH.
>> Laura: A LITTLE BIT BUT NOT A
LOT OF THE VALUES OF THESE
HOMES.
SO WHAT HAPPENS.
>> I WOULD DEFER TO THE EXPERTS
ON THE FINANCIAL SERVICES
COMMITTEE WHAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN.
BUT I'M ALWAYS RELUCTANT TO
EMBRACE ANY TYPE OF BIG
GOVERNMENT SOLUTION, CERTAINLY
BIG FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SOLUTION.
WE TYPICALLY SCREW IT UP AS
EVIDENCED BY THIS INFLATION
REDUCTION ACT WHICH WE KNOW IS
ACTUALLY DRIVING UP THE COSTS OF
GOODS